[Music]
welcome everyone to the next
live session of amazon's consumer
science summit
i'm sam eldersville the director of
research for ipc at scott
and i'm going to be your moderator for
the next hour or so
i'm really happy to announce that our
speaker for the next session
the nasim telev should require no
introduction
professor to love is currently the
distinguished professor at
risk engineering and nyu's camden school
of engineering
but prior to this he spent 21 years as a
financial risk taker
or what i like to call a quantitative
trader
before becoming a researcher in
philosophical mathematical and practical
problems with probability professor
taleb is the author of the five volume
essay on uncertainty
that has been published in over 40
languages this essay concerto
includes the volumes the black swan
fooled by randomness
anti-fragile skin in the game
and the most recent volume of the
serious series he will explore today
the statistical consequences of fat
tails
professor tuleb is also the author of
more than 50 scholarly papers
in mathematical statistics genetics
quantitative finance
physics philosophy ethics economics
and international affairs after
professor tulep's talk today we will
have a brief q a session
so please make sure to type your
questions into the broadcast
chat bar to the right of the screen in
the live session
i note that there have been some people
have noted that their screens had frozen
momentarily in one of the previous
presentations
this happens to you please refresh your
browser
and without further ado i give you
professor tulip for the next live
session
they have science consumer science
great thank you thanks thanks sam for
inviting me
and thank you amazon i'm going to say uh
the reason why
i'm usually not known for being
extremely um
generous with phrase but i but
amazon is the reason i exist because
when i wrote food by randomness the
first volume of the inserto
nobody carried it uh you know bookstores
said
you know is it finance is it philosophy
is it they couldn't understand that
something could be multidisciplinary and
uh
and bookstore did not like to carry my
book so the but amazon saved me because
you know you start to have an online
activity and
uh and and of course uh it led to a
market
for uh something that you you cannot put
in a
special section in the bookstore it's
the same thing
with with the you know because my
activities you know you don't have you
if nobody's paying me to define myself
nobody's paying my salary i don't have
to define myself
it's the same thing with writing anyway
so
this time i'm writing about uh actually
it's uh the first volume of the
technical insert though it's outside the
insert so there's a companion
and this is the first of three volumes
uh
this one is on consequences of fat tail
which sort of maps to the idea of the
black swan
and the other two volume the second one
is on convexity and the third volume is
on errors in higher dimensional data
you know analysis and i mean sort of the
cursive dimensionality this is volume
three is
mostly on uh when i when i started
getting involved
in matrix theory i rediscovered stuff i
knew intuitively as a trainer and i put
in football randomness so uh my idea of
the uncerto is
is is everything that's technical can be
technical but you put it on the side
so this is an idea this uh the problem
the story of my life with fat tales is
as follows
people say well now we're gonna use the
fat tail uh
in place of tin tails yeah like changing
the color of the dress this is what i
call
this error no it's different number one
we don't understand fat tails
okay saying the distribution fat tail
forces you to change a lot of things and
the title of actually this book is
real world pre-asymptotics epistemology
and application
pre-asymptotics why because everything
is based
that we know on the law of large numbers
that's the philosophical problem of
induction
so how many you know observation you
need to be comfortable
with your statistical claim
which is a subsection of the problem of
induction and and basically we're lost
on the fat tails because we can't do the
same thing
so before we go further the way i
classify
fat tails is at the bottom of
you know distribution is a degenerate
distribution which is basically
degenerate
is uh it's actually a mathematical word
as uh
i know you have so many phds they don't
know it's not polite but it means
distribution was no randomness and then
you have the bernoulli distribution and
then you have thin tails from the
standard
you know some of bernoulli's becoming uh
binomial
and then you have so up so so
really it's never really uh uh
doesn't deliver affinities it's compact
support but it's sort of gaussian
by convergence and then you have a
gaussian that has no compact support but
you know
pseudo compact support and then you have
the cusp is the exponential sub
exponential the exponential basically
deciding in that zone we start entering
fatter tail domains
and then as you go as you go to the
right here you have to forget about it
means that the law of large numbers will
never work
here l1 means that you have the norm l1
only the mean exists and you can't use
any
higher moments which is basically your
status statistics
and let me let me explain this with more
intuitive
presentation uh now with with
this following quiz and then we go back
to doing math
um i have i select randomly from the
population
two people and the total height is four
meters ten centimeters
what's the most likely distribution okay
well i mean not 10 centimeters at 4
meters okay
so there is a domain and this pretty
much defines the domain that is not
self-exponential
in which you're vastly more likely to
get two times three sigma events then
one times six at my length
see and that domain is was what i called
in the in the graph the crimea condition
and it's very simple
it tells you that if you're gonna take a
losses insurance companies it's going to
come from a lot of small hits
okay a big loss would be a lot of small
hits not a big hit
because vastly more likely to get a lot
of three sigma events and one times
nines at my event or
uh twas in my event or so on so so
here we have the ratio of the square for
two independent observation
uh so it's a survival function probably
exceeding k
square over uh probability of having 2k
events you know an event of 2k size
you know in other words a six sigma
versus here
uh the the probability of having two
three sigmas
independent and then you see as k gets
bigger how the thing explodes
for a certain class of distribution now
if
if i do the the the the the if i ask you
uh you know now you have a
random selection of two people and and
the compound
wealth is uh say 40 million dollars
what's the most like distribution
distribution
i think in the example i used 36 million
36 million dollars what's the
what's that what do you think sam is
going to be the most likely allocation
18 and 18.
a random select and i have two people
and it happens that the sum is 36
million which is a tail event
see there is a domain in which you're
vastly more likely to get a ten sigma
event than two times five sigma events
and adversely more likely to get a 20
sigma event than two times
a testing by that so this we can explain
it um
very simply here with this graph the
iso densities for two independent
gaussians
uh that on this graph i show uh
that the total where the total of this
is the iso densities
these are the deviation for one for the
other one
and then pretty much that the the when
you have a tail event
but the most likely uh place is where
they're both
4.1 and 4.1 on the other hand for the
other domain
i'm cheating by modifying a little bit
because you can't have a negative of a
negative height but
the amount of negative wealth in this
case
it's either one has 36 million or the
other has 36 million
because the the the joint to independent
okay would be uh something called
non-elliptical
that's in higher dimension which is my
new interest since i finished this book
this volume one which actually is
collection of papers anyway
so this is a way to see the difference
between these two
or to really see it here in the real
world that
if the boss tells you at year end
you know if you lose more than 100
million dollars explain to me what
events calls them
ozar is going to be one in the fat tales
and and this helps us for example
understand the difference between
a lot of things why is it that we have
to worry about kovid
although kovit hasn't killed as many
people as other diseases
someone tells you you know uh
you have a a billion people dying uh in
in 2022
what what you know you know it gotta
come from a fat tail thing
okay so conditional on two billion
people dying
odds are it came you look from a tail to
the body
odds are it came from a
something that's very fat tailed which
is can be only a
contagious uh you know uh pandemic or
a war the two fattest tailed
risk we are facing today so now
if i die and you want to remember my
work or something like that
okay this slide will explain it all it's
a working of the law of large numbers
so look up up top how the law of large
number converges very fast for gaussian
okay and look at the bottom for pareto
80 20 with the same
mean mean deviation say how many more
observations you need to stabilize the
mean
you see pareto 80 20 is a
in a class of fat tail distribution that
we saw in the graph up all the way up
north
and uh and and of course uh you know it
doesn't have a variance doesn't have a
lot of things still
the large number works but very slowly
so you have what i call pre-asymptotics
so here here you notice how long it
takes
and uh and the best way
you know to figure it out is is
by by looking at you know the
convergence properties
and you notice the following and and
this is the maybe technical
uh it's deriving a few papers and it's
this book
but if i ask a statistician i tell them
listen
uh you need a n of 30 for a gaussian to
be comfortable with the mean
how much more n for the drop you know to
be you know to lower
uh the variance of your estimator
how much more data do you need
foreign typically they tell me maybe
twice as much
three times let's not exaggerate all
right three times
that's that was all my life you know how
much more data do we need
you need 2 10 to the 14 times more data
so this book has uh chapter
3 which is the the casual i mean casual
less non-casual chapter of the book and
in chapter three i i cover uh
you know the things that that that the
consequences
that's called consequences of fat tales
the title the consequences and
consequence one
the law of large number where it works
works too slowly in the real world
okay in other words you need all you
always almost always need more data
so and it cancels a lot of statistical
estimators
so this is the consequence number one uh
i have this is more technical here i'm
defining what do i mean by certain class
called power law which is all the way at
the top
uh so you have gaussian basin and then
you have something called the
exponential which is
really rare and then up the top you have
the power law class
and then i show visibly why finance is
in the power law class we showed
how pandemics are in power all class a
lot of things in that class
if you're in that class you need to work
on your estimators because
you cannot get the mean very easily so
that's of classic was number one
we can easily verify in the s p 500
there's some
technique called maximum to some ratio i
won't bore you
but visibly the moments don't converge
you see people are fooled by the fact
that in sample you always have a mean
you put the excess spreadsheet you say
you know average you get the average you
get variance you always have a variance
even the process doesn't have a variance
you see so but there are techniques to
figure out if the mean converges in your
sample or stuff to to be to able to rule
out gaussianity and
effectively we can for the s p 500 we
can for a lot of things
now the other one you may tell me well
you know what
how can you prove to me that it's a
power law but effectively very simply
very very very simply okay if you have
you witness a 10 sigma event what is
called the 10 sigma event
in the gaussian world something we
observe in finance practically daily
more than once okay you're going to have
one variable every day something in
finance that has 10 sigma
and you have days when you have 20 30 40
of them depends on how many
securities you're tracking you see so
so i've seen all my life these ten sigma
so i know i know from the beginning but
that's a very simple reasoning
the reasoning is going to be as follows
okay if someone tells you it's a 10
sigma event i e the probability is very
very tiny
the 10 sigma happens every 10 to the
minus 23.
yeah sorry 1 1 10 23 you know
days so you know definitely
that it's more likely that they're using
the wrong probability distribution
then that probability distribution
delivered an event of 10 to 23 and the
way i prove it using bayes
bayes rule that unless you have a
hundred percent
certainty that your distribution can
only be gaussian
okay unless you
you know you know you have total
certainty
you had this slightly you know uh
non-certainty in your prior in other
words can be 99.99
gaussian okay and you have a 10 sigma
event then you reject the probability
of the distribution that you watched is
gaussian
and an event here i call survivorship in
other words exceed probably
exceeding something so in other words to
summarize if someone tells you it's a 10
sigma event
it's vastly more likely that that person
doesn't know
okay the uh statistics or distribution
then it's a 10 sigma event see and and
and but that's so common
like for example we had people who had
that pseudonobel in economics
the swedish rights banks you know prize
who after ltcm said oh we had a lot of
10 sigma events
if you're saying that you cannot say we
had a 10 single event
okay it's not like unless god told you
god only can
the world can only be gaussian you see
it tells you the world is not gaussian
if the world's not gaussian
then there are a lot of consequences and
now a lot of people in finance a lot of
people in economics have said oh
no we're under fat tales but then they
didn't take it to the consequences
the consequences uh um that that
that you know effectively once you you
have to rule out something and then you
have to have be a little more vigilant
on your uh in your approach
now i use this confirmatory empiricism
to to to prove it
and the logic is as follows let's say
that i have desired distribution
okay and then once in a while boom i
have an additional variation
i can rule out it is degenerate i can
say it's random non-degenerate
but if i see just the this what i have
on the left or pointing the cursor is
sam is the cursor showing yes cursor is
showing
so when i'm showing the cursor here can
i say is there evidence that there's no
randomness no
that's the fundamental asymmetry i can
reject degenerate
okay you see i cannot accept the
distribution degenerate so you start
ranking i can reject that the
distribution of thin tails
i cannot reject the distribution as fat
tail for very same
uh asymmetry fundamental asymmetry
and that's pretty much the theme of the
black swan and that's the black swan
the logical black swan problem ported
into statistics
you see i can reject okay the
non-existence of black swans
okay but i cannot reject the existence
of black swans
okay unless i've seen all black swans
which is you know
all swans which of course is initial to
sampling theory
so consequence number two and then we
can go with consequences till
uh you know we stop here the mean of
distribution will very correspond to a
sample mean
it will always will have a sample small
sample effect downward upward
particularly one distribution is skewed
so and let me explain
if the distribution is skewed okay
you're going to have
where the the the are
the missing observation to the right in
that section we don't see here
you see above the maximum observation
so there they are you know there there
is a mass
to that density you don't see it when
you do parametric non-parametric
approaches or you do other distribution
so that part of distribution
would play a large role for the mean
you see and uh and and that's one
so and then we made a statement with my
co-author shirillo in our paper on kovid
for our paper on pandemics in general
how they are fat tailed
and then all these things uh that were
you know sort of like not understood in
this course
uh that our central point we told them
the fatter the tail distribution the
more the tail wagged the dog
the means the more you have observations
the fewer the observations that
determine all the statistical properties
and all
these are entails okay so in other words
the the body has less and less
significance when the
the the distribution is fatter and
fatter tail
and um and for those you know who
are familiar with power laws it's the
alpha exponent of the power law the
lower the alpha exponent of the power
law
uh the the more the property come from
the tails both tails now if you only
have one tail
because the distribution is you know
just
skewed or one-tailed then you have the
richest the the most important part
of the distribution is what you do not
see you see
simply you do not see the most important
part okay
now we have to figure it out by
parametric analysis
and we approach that to something we
call the shadow mean
you see the the unseen rare event tried
to fill in this
based on properties that we derived from
the body distribution
so we looked at wars we looked at you
know we started using the method of
shadow mean it's filling in the mean
from that unseen observation via
extrapolation for
and and who does it did it implicitly
not explicitly
the dutch when they wanted to build uh
you know walls because they
they sort of like don't want to drown so
that which is very legitimate concern on
the part of the dutch
and then they said we're not going to
make the mistake of
the the which actually was made in
fukushima by taking all the past
observation and saying oh what's the
maximum variation okay let's hedge for
that
okay not thinking that that can be
exceeded okay
so so they uh so the dutch
started techniques called extreme value
theory that effectively allow us to fill
in that
missing mean and start applying it so
we can say for example okay the observed
mean
is 9 meters but the true mean is going
to be more like 11.
you see and and work to fill in
something and the conditional mean
conditional on being higher than 9
meters is going to be much higher
so we can work with fat tails but we
just have to be honest and reject
all the nonsense a thing that do not
belong there
not patch up you know as as many people
have patched up
consequence number five i'm i'm
resigning constant questions the way
they're presented in in the book
robot statistics is not robust and the
empirical distribution is not empirical
for the reasons we just saw here okay
and prove that analytically
that robot statistics only work for sin
tails robot statistics being
whatever approach non-parametric
statistics that really
gives you a number that's not going to
be shocked by an observation
and here there's an error made in a
paper by someone
who's a nobel in economics where they
say historical data suggests that the
base rate for severe single day stock
market crash is not relatively low and
how people overestimated
effectively if you read my book or if
you see you know my
my real activities as a traitor and i
still is represented by universa that
continued with my former colleagues
and where i have steak if you see that
you see that we believe
that the stock market doesn't
you know underestimate the tails the the
the the option market underestimate the
tail
you see so we see that analytically we
proved it
no but here they're doing naive
technique uh
which is basically they take the worst
that happened and think that
it's not gonna be toppled okay but if
you use extreme value theory and use
you know proper distribution you're
going to get uh
you know what what i'm saying is that
something that something may be
overpriced but not based on
naive analysis but this is rampant in
economics
uh consequence three uh they're not in
sequence uh
here uh standard deviations and variants
are not usable
well why well you know because
uh for fat tails mean deviation
is a much better method if it exists and
and vastly more robust and and i tried
to one i i tried to figure out and this
i explained in chapter three
and or in chapter four as well
i couldn't understand why people use
standard deviation
standard deviation is a very very weird
operator
where you're weighing an observation by
itself so when you have a tail event
okay you're you're multiplying it by
itself
rather mean deviation you weigh an
observation
you know equally you weigh all
observation equally so you weighted by
itself
it turned out i looked it turned out
that
uh fisher discovered that is slightly
more efficient for the gaussian to use
standard deviation than mean deviation
more efficient mean to use the
colloquial english
means you need a slightly fewer
observation to get a good number
right but it turned out here as i show
look uh the mean deviation versus
standard deviation for a
for a power law that has finite variance
sorry i
i let me go back here okay
look at the distribution of mean
deviation of the zero standard deviation
for the gaussian right underneath slight
advantage but look how the difference is
big
which means that standard deviation is
going to be much more stochastic
and not a good measure well even when it
does exist
you see and uh and here i show what i
call the relative efficiency ratio of
one versus the other
slightly better here 0.875
one being equal and then here you go to
eight times
better under uh uh slightly fatter tales
so basically
variance doesn't mean anything it
doesn't represent uh uh
anything uh on the fat tail i mean more
and more because becomes more and more
irrelevant
and and of course you have uh undefined
variance or infinite variance
uh beta sharp ratio and commonly
hackneyed
financial metrics are uninformative and
that is a a very important property
and to give you anyway why why why
the sharp ratio why the variance is
uninformative or another example
is what is the variance of the variance
it's a kurtosis
you see so kurtosis if you look at it
that way the variance of the variance
you know that kurtosis pretty much
doesn't exist for all of these
and let me give you uh one the first
paper really i wrote for international
journal forecasting
given that i was never an academic i
just decided to become an academic
when i got tired of training and the
first paper i took
um this line here the s p 56 years of s
p and showed that one single day
in 56 years represents 79
of the total kurtosis
so it means one observation 56 years
gonna give you eighty percent of your
total
all right that means that kurtosis
number right is
is is not stable or i mean to be polite
that's not stable in fact it's undefined
doesn't exist
now if kurtosis doesn't exist it tells
you the variance
is very unstable it's not representative
and that's pretty much what's behind it
so and then i i showed it for all
financial instruments
and effectively you have silver 94
percent of observation in one day that
was as of 2008
what happens is as you have more more
tail events maybe that number will
change
uh favorably or unfavorable in case of s
p the largest observation now is maybe
only 60
because we had two of them but still you
take the top
three or four observations they
represent for all of them close to 99
of kurtosis okay i'm talking about 60
years 56 years by now it's
66 years all right that was from 10
years ago
now this is gonna be sore okay linear
response
regression doesn't work when you have
you know i mean amazon your sales are
fat-tailed
i don't know what what what is sentailed
in your world maybe the height
of the members of your team uh
the weight of the members of your team
their water consumption may be centailed
but believe me your sales a lot of these
numbers
are very fat tails right that deal so
when you do leader regression i don't
understand how they do leave your
regression was fat-tailed
because the very assumption okay
you require the gauss-microfield which
requires
gaussianity okay or some form of
gaussianity
this is uh now i show here
when you regress things that are uh
i was like income income is very fat
tail when you address income to
measures like iq because i don't believe
you even iq for for this reason because
i saw the paper that said okay
you're not going to convince me that iq
works because your numbers don't mean
anything for me
and let me give you an example here i
constructed an example
where i'm regressing a koshi where one
variable is koshi i'm regressing it
against something else
i know the the the the correlation is
zero my construction okay
look at the r square i know the r square
is going to be zero my construction
here most of the most of what you see is
ninety eight and a half percent
so in other words you have
overestimation of the r square
okay aside from the fact
that if you violate the cause markov or
find some theorem that allows you to
operate this
then i tell you okay now show me your
numbers because kurtosis is infinite
okay and in many of these
so this is another example where you
construct something and you see the
distribution of r square all decent but
in fact you know it's zero
uh now now here when you go in higher
dimension it's a little sadder
uh high dimension which is why my volume
three of the technical inserto
is focused on higher dimension the
cursive dimensionality
you know is compounded so let me uh give
you a little idea here a lot of large
numbers for uh pcas principal components
uh i'm sure i mean practically everybody
now does musical components
and this is this this is a one effect
it's not the wigner effect it's an
effect this is covered by vigner the
figure effect is something else
but he he looked at random matrices and
and and of course notice
that you have uh
say this is uh if you if you generate a
random matrix and
and basically all correlations are zero
and sample you're going to have higher
correlation
uh this is what you see here uh
you're going to put the rank the pcas
you're going to have a nice pca
ranking that goes down and as you
increase your sample size because of a
large number the thing becomes flat
okay now in this case i go from
n of 30 to n
of a hundred a thousand sorry end of 30
to end of a thousand
sorry sorry no uh uh uh
i go for 30 variables from n of 100 to
an end of a thousand
okay so here this is n of a hundred
another thousand you see it doesn't take
much
to show you that there's independence
you say that is a a high dimensional
matrix say you cannot reduce the
dimension
because if correlations are zero you
cannot really reduce the dimensions
so this is of the equivalent of law of
large numbers
where you don't need much to see the pca
okay and the randomness washes out after
a while because look how quickly or
randomness washes out here
at the bottom you do the same for fat
tails
no effect you will always have a
dominant pca
although we know they're all flat by
construction they're all flat
and look what you see and you go from a
hundred to a thousand
you still see this you go from from a
hundred two thousand to a million
observation and you still see this okay
and they should be flat okay you need
infinity to get flat
so this is and uh this shows us
effectively how we're fooled by
randomness
by these uh things i will not
you know never miss an opportunity to
explain that everything in finance is
based
academically on portfolio selection not
practically
that requires sigma to the okay so
it doesn't work okay and uh
yeah now there's something called
there's something they discovered to
patch it up
about uh ellipticality that an
elliptically contoured distribution
that you can have in the liquid you know
that if the
the distribution are elliptical then
maybe
even under fat tails these theorems work
well i showed that distribution are not
elliptical
in finance and uh and other people have
shown that as well
so so it's like let not waste time and
patch
existing methods by let's get deeper
another way i convey the idea that
distribution's analytical for someone
who doesn't
know uh you guys know my book sales so i
guess
one of the readers of the inserto that's
not technical okay now
today i'm technical um i'm trying to
explain to them why this is nonsense
i would skip all this ellipticality and
and and show this graph
i say the everything in finance is based
on
knowing the joint distribution at
infinity
okay of all these things not only
knowing it and and with certainty in
other words that the correlation will
not change the only sampling error
this is a correlation with gold to s p
look at this
so basically the only thing that seems
to be interesting in this
the only information we get is that
the correlation is never above one and
never below minus one
these things are very very very unstable
so if correlation is unstable you cannot
work with a correlation matrix
that's sort of like my my watered-down
explanation
of of the problem so
there are other problems with
diversification versus
tail hedging that's technical
there are other problems but but now i'm
going to stop given that i don't see my
audience i don't know my audience have
been too technical less technical i'm
going to
summarize do i have two minutes to
summarize sam
okay so i'm going to summarize in two
minutes what i said
this is about the statistical
consequence of fat tails let's say now
everyone you seem to know what fat tails
are very good very nice now why on earth
are you using a standard deviation
why on earth are you using this why
nurse are you using pcas
why nursing if you accept that
distribution is not fat tail
you cannot match up the existing methods
so
that was sort of like my theme my main
theme
but then within that we try to look at
what we can do
because there are things we can do the
most important thing the most beautiful
thing i think
is that story about the dutch people who
raise you know digs or something
that's we can do all right we can
definitely figure out where the unseen
tail if we cannot compute it but we can
figure out
what it is once we figure out something
is fat tailed we know how what action
what policy we should take
we also know how to distinguish between
distribution it's so easy
to know if the distribution is fat tail
and if it is fat tail it's very very
very easy to figure out what to do about
it
you see and and of course we love
a conventional statistical method they
seem to work in many places although
sometimes
not always but this is uh so this is
uh the message uh from here
stop using bad tools
and and if no statistic you cannot get
averages but
for there's some techniques we use to
get the shadow mean
uh there are other techniques uh i you
know
we use for other things to to be able to
reject entailedness and therefore adopt
some policies such as some ranking of
what we call fat talentness that we can
do there are a lot of tricks
um they're like some details how to
compute the genie coefficient
if you take the genie coefficient the
way they compare it from directly from
observing the the
mean it doesn't work the way you got to
do it is
you use have a bunch of papers on how to
use parametric methods
and uh
i mean it's nice uh uh that you can
really uh reject science
bad science using science it took me a
long time spend my life working on on
tricks like that
and uh even optional pricing people say
you can't price option on the fat tail
before you know using back of the
envelope method and now progressively
more scientifically
using uh you know as we understand the
tale so the story of my life is story of
understanding the tale
and uh and and we price options on the
fat tails all right
so there's no nothing just but i don't
know there's something about research
that is not very honest go into areas
where people can squeeze a paper because
they've been published in econometrica
and therefore it's fine and you know it
doesn't work but you know what you get
you got to go
you get a good job you get publication
good job you get
a good google scholar everybody's happy
that it doesn't you know
there's something about this that smells
bad
so thank you for listening to me thanks
and thanks sam